can you just firstly remind our viewers
on why you felt you had to resign from
your post
well mine was a little bit different
from lord guys although lord i think has
since agreed with me with his
resignation letter what i was saying was
that when the prime minister responded
to the sugree report he was urged to
come up with a reply which addressed
whether or not um the survey report said
that he'd broken the ministerial code or
not and he was very very focused on
whether or not he broke the ministerial
code by being issued with a fixed
penalty notice if you remember by the
police didn't really address the
main
criticism in the supreme report which
was the failure of leadership that
sugrade described it as the report said
and of course leadership at number 10 of
the culture the organization that
allowed all those parties to happen
is one of the central seven principles
of integrity and public life they're
called the nolan principles they run
like a sticker rock right the way
through the middle of the ministerial
code and it was pretty hard i thought to
conclude that the prime minister wasn't
being criticized for breaking
ministerial code and when he didn't
really address that i just felt i had to
go but i'm i'm i'm very sorry that it
came to that obviously it wasn't a
decision which i took very lightly and
but that was my reason and i think that
lord guyt actually backed it up as one
of the points he made in his letter uh
when he when he resigned uh earlier on
this week
you say that law guy you felt backed up
that principle but to be honest i think
most people would find it a bit more
easy to get their heads around i guess
if lord gait had resigned for the
reasons that you did and you know he he
didn't go
over the parties at number 10 or over
the flat refurbishment instead it seemed
like he decided to quit after a request
for advice about tariffs on chinese
steel i mean it doesn't really feel like
a smoking gun does it
well and that's been the sort of the big
open question you're absolutely right i
mean everyone's been reading his letter
he's since published a further
clarification but there's an awful lot
of
missing details about precisely what it
was that he was being asked to
to to opine on um and so that's still
sort of an open question which i think
people will still be looking for answers
for because no one can quite understand
why a trade deal might involve a breach
of the ministerial code or not so that's
still an outstanding uh and an open
question which we don't know the answer
to yet
do you think that really you know part
of the reason that he went is because of
a build-up i guess uh over
things like the ministerial code and how
it applies to partygate and receiving
that fine
it was pretty clear from his letter yes
that this was if you like the the final
straw that broke the camel's back um and
that he'd been sort of getting more and
more uncomfortable over time one of the
things that made him uncomfortable as i
said was the reason why i resigned about
a week earlier and but yeah ultimately
we will have to see whether or not he
there's any more clarification he can he
can offer um or indeed whether or not
parliament wants to see what it was that
he was being asked to to opine on um but
we'll have to wait and see about that
one as you say still many questions to
be answered i think now one of the
reasons i was keen to talk to you about
this subject today is because it feels
as if number 10 well they have said that
they are now reviewing
the post of ethics advisor in its
entirety do you think they might scrap
it well i hope they won't i think that
the ethics advisor does something really
important and while it's quite possible
you do need to update and upgrade and
modernize these things every once in a
while it's quite possible to
amend it a bit i think that if they do
anything other than strengthen it then i
think
they will lose a lot of credibility
and they will also
miss out on a job that urgently needs to
be done i think over the last few months
clearly demonstrate that it has to
happen so yes there are a couple of
things they could do to improve it to
strengthen it to modernize it and
scrapping which is not part of that
do you think that part of it might be
driven for the fact that
it might be quite difficult to get
anybody to do the job
because
well i i think that there will be an
issue with finding somebody yes um but i
think that if they strengthen the role
i've made a couple of suggestions about
how that might happen it becomes more
doable if you make it stronger and
therefore it will become i think more
attractive to the kind of
sturdily independent high caliber person
they're going to need to have to give
the role credibility and therefore to
sort of restore the credibility in this
area of the ministerial code and of
number 10. so yes it can be done um but
they'll need to strengthen it in order
to make it attractive to the right kind
of person
the right kind of person being someone
who will stand up to boris johnson is
that what you mean
yes absolutely and not just boris
johnson that the whole point about this
role is that they need to be willing to
stand up to any prime minister um yeah
whoever they may be boris johnson or any
of his successors over the next you know
10 20 30 years you've got to have
somebody who isn't afraid to speak truth
to power now i just want to talk to you
a little bit about the uh confidence uh
motion 148 mps of course voting to say
they had no confidence in the prime
minister we heard from grant schatz
earlier on the program who quite
interestingly said he predicted that
number and was just worn out in his
prediction which is quite uh remarkable
actually uh but he was making the point
that he thinks now most people want
everyone to move on for the prime
minister to focus on doing the job
looking at the situation in ukraine etc
is that analysis correct or do you think
that uh a significant number of
conceptual mps are still
harboring those concerns about his
leadership
well i think that the
by winning the vote even though i'm sure
he would have wanted to win it but much
more handily and with a bigger margin
but by winning the vote i think the
prime minister has won himself a bit of
time um and people like me and others we
have to respect the result of that vote
we have to accept it and respect it and
i think everybody does and that means
that the prime minister's got a little
bit of time to
you know deliver the reset that he's
already said he wants to do he knows
he's got to build some you know rebuild
some bridges if you like so he's he said
he wants to do that i think that's
entirely the right thing for him to do
but i don't think that rebuilding
bridges will just involve ignoring the
issue because i don't think ethics works
that way i don't think that integrity
works the way i think you've got to show
that you're changing what you're doing
and you're changing how you do it in
order to address the concerns you can't
just ignore them and pretend it didn't
happen
on sunday reporting today uh that some
mps are looking at potentially changing
the rules around confidence motions so
that another one could be held after six
months
is that correct
well i think that would be a decision
for
sigron brady who runs the the 1922
committee which is kind of like the the
trade union if you like for for
conservative mps
and i
my guess is that what he would i think
he's actually said this publicly is that
there's not much point in changing the
rules unless it's quite likely that
another vote would come up with a
different result um so i think it would
require quite a lot of uh conservative
mps who voted in favor of the prime
minister in the last vote to come to him
privately and say look i've changed my
mind and only at that point didn't make
very much sense otherwise you're just
sort of going through
sort of party constitutional hoops for
no very good practical purpose and
what's the point of that
but it would be uh possible to do uh if
enough concerto mps indicated that
they'd like to see another one
well at that point there's a process and
and the
votes and stuff like that but yes you
could do it um but i think that everyone
is
playing that one quite carefully and not
wanting sort of fan of the flames of
that idea just because there's not much
point um if if the reset works if the
prime minister persuades people if he
rebuilds the bridges that he said he
wants to do um then it all becomes a bit
sort of a theoretical argument i think
is the point
okay that makes sense uh thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning john penrose there